on them than we do yeah
yeah because he knows him from there
from the indian chassis and
okay so anish now is trying to come as a
plan we we gave ya i mean what else
nothing is left king c5 he played a
tempo catch one what's the
what's his plan uh it means that after
king this is
catch five let's say something like that
you cannot
if you move the hook i take the pawn if
you move the pawn i take the pawn
uh yeah that's the position we get on
the board
it is over no chance for any guillotine
here
the suk strong yeah it's even
worse i think by now g6 played
yeah just bishop c6 here or something
like that yeah
horrible such one
amazing and the next opponent
of the world champion is known it will
be
radek voitachek ubi20 maxim matlakov
bishop c6 this is just a song
oh that's really
yeah i think you can just play bishop d5
back yeah you have to
i think this you give chances again yeah
yeah not really also knight d3 and
okay it's uh e pawn is too good yeah
okay but bishop d5 is just uh
did you play bishop d7 look
let's close the box that would be funny
um
and anna ushina former woman world
champion
equalized so against
maya music truck two more games to play
at least yeah so now bishop h3 yeah
sure is very fun i play bishop c6
um that's weird actually takes only five
yeah but position is pretty dead
you move the knight and you start
pushing your e pull now
marching yeah 97 yeah
yeah the guy was tricky yeah yeah
okay 97
and it is ready
okay whatever if he went to night
night night even more accurate i guess
wow it's amazing another top 10 player
will be out of the tournament
in a few seconds it seems
and only two players remaining
from the world top 10 in the tournament
magnus carson of course
and sasha chuck that's it
just i mean if anish
loses but we expect him to
to lose here i mean no way there's
nothing to do with seven is coming
and then 95 that's the simplest e7 will
be played
that's for sure
and
i do sort of visibly a bit excited a bit
nervous but okay
i mean he's a young
[Music]
young man about to make uh
yeah i mean it's the biggest upset yes
ever done so
that's amazing to knock out one of the
best players in the world 95
okay i i guess anish will design now
yeah
congratulations to nordi beck
abdul satorov this is just amazing what
he did
and we cannot say that uh it's
undeserved
i mean it's fully deserved
it was dominating that much sure only
only the last game he was
suffering yeah a lot but generally
speaking yeah he
he looked good yeah he looked incredibly
good so we'll of course
continue to to to follow everything and
we have some new